let's say there's a trolley and some
tracks on those tracks are five mile the
trolley is barreling down these tracks
and you know with absolute certainty
that it will hit those five men although
there is a side track with one man on it
in front of you is a switch if you push
it the charlie will change directions
and strike and kill the single man if
you do nothing the trolley will strike
and kill all five men what do you do do
you play an active role but condemn the
man on the Left track to death or do you
do nothing but allow five individuals to
die this is a classic ethics thought
experiment most people agree that they
should divert the trolley and kill the
one man it works for the greater good
and mitigates risk now in a different
scenario let's say you're standing on a
bridge over the trolley tracks and once
again there's a trolley barreling down
towards five individuals on the track
standing next to you as a man so fat
that you know that if you were to push
him on the tracks he would stop the
trolley in its tracks and save the five
individuals far fewer people say that
they would push the man in this
circumstance and say that they would
divert the trolley in the first
circumstance they are just not
comfortable taking such an active role
in the fat man's death these thought
experiments are just hypotheticals and
it's unlikely that anyone would ever
have to make those decisions
however ethicists and developers are now
having to create algorithms to dictate
what our autonomous car to the future
should do in similar ethical conundrums
unlike humans self-driving cars will
have the ability to carefully choose
their response to an oncoming collision
and will need a set of pre designated
rules to dictate what they should do in
the event of an unavoidable collision
one thought would just be to tell the
cars to follow the laws the problem with
this is that there aren't really laws
for these situations many laws are
written concerning that ethics is a
messy and fluid concept when judging a
situation one can never really know what
motivate an individual to choose a
certain action but with self-driving
cars we will be able to understand the
decision making process additionally
following the laws could be harmful in
some situations
for example let's say a vehicle stopped
at a traffic light and there's a
pedestrian in the crosswalk directly in
front of the car
the car detects that a truck is coming
in too fast from behind and will hit the
car the car cannot move forward without
hitting the pedestrian there are two
options the car can do nothing stay put
get hit by the truck and therefore hit
the pedestrian in front or alternatively
the car can move forward hit the
pedestrian but avoid being hit by the
truck from our perspective it probably
seems right for the car to move and hit
the pedestrian however this would mean
that it was a car in your industry annow
the truck this presents tricky legal and
ethical questions on whether the car is
now at fault for the injuries a
pedestrian or if the truck is given the
laws we have now it's possible that the
fault would be laid upon the car another
question is who is at fault for an
accident with a self-driving car
considering that there isn't a human
driving is it the owner of the vehicles
fault
now let's say that the pedestrian was
moving fast enough that you would no
longer be in front of the car at the
time of impact between the truck and the
car but that in order for the car to
move out of the path before the time of
impact between the truck in the car it
would need to have the pedestrian is it
now ethical for the car to injure the
pedestrian even though the pedestrian
would likely escape injury if the car
didn't move does it depend on the number
of people in the car what if the car had
a mother of three and the pedestrian was
a felon would it be different if the car
had a felon in it and the pedestrian was
a mother of three that's where these
ethical questions become even Messier
another school of thought is that the
self-driving cars should be programmed
to save the most human lies or caused
the least possible injury however there
are issues with this solution as well
let's think about another situation say
there are two motorcycles coming down
towards a self-driving car on a road
that is too narrow for the different
vehicles to pass each other the car does
not have enough time to slow down and
there is no where to veer one
motorcyclist has a helmet on and one
does not should the car hit the
motorcyclist with a helmet on because
his injuries might be less
severe or should the car hit the
motorcyclist who does not have a helmet
on because he did not properly protect
himself if cars were programmed to hit
the motorcyclists with the helmet that
would mean that in a way it would become
safer to ride without a helmet it's a
tricky situation altogether and a real
ethical conundrum it's very difficult
for humans to explain or justify the
rules behind our own ethics so that's
why these questions are so difficult to
answer for this reason a proposed
solution to program self-driving cars is
moral modeling essentially programming
by example the computer will be
presented with a situation and a human
or ideally an ethics board would tell
the computer what the ethical solution
would be over time the computer would
learn how to emulate the ethics of a
human and essentially make the same
decisions that a human would make these
are all situations that are very
unlikely to happen but with how
prevalent autonomous cars are likely
become the algorithms that will
determine how to crash could choose the
fate of dozens of lives each year
however autonomous cars are predicted to
save upwards of 30,000 lives per year
once they are widespread these ethics
may become a hotly contested issue in a
few years however if these negotiations
prevent or slow down the spread of
driverless cars many more lives can be
lost
than would ever be determined by the
so-called death algorithm
what's easy
you asked me to be nice at the end you
write clean one way of looking at the
ocean